hello everyone and welcome to round
eight of this year's European Team
Championship it is Norway versus
Netherlands and on board one Magnus
Carlson faces his first 2700 opponent in
the event Jordan v forz playing board
one for Netherlands and uh it's quite an
interesting game uh quite a clean one
and uh very very different from the
let's say previous seven that Magnus
already played in this event so let's
check it out Magnus still without a loss
Jordan did lose one game in round six n
Nikita vugo then he drew a shage in
round seven and now he faces Magnus so
let's check out what happened here
Magnus opened with E4 E5 we have Knight
to F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5
going for the ru Lopez we have Knight to
F6 the Berlin defense uh and castles we
have Knight captures on e4 uh Rook to E1
and now Knight to D6 so very very
standard stuff been played thousands of
times and Knight captures on E5 is the
standard move here but Magnus goes for
A4 is the third most popular
continuation but also been played by
very very strong players uh Bishop to D7
and Knight to C3 so just continuing
development A6 challenging the bishop
Bishop to F1 and pawn to E4 giving back
the pawn Knight captures and E4 Knight
captures Rook captures and now you freed
up the D file so Pawn to D5 we have Rook
to D1 uh Pawn to D4 stopping Magnus from
playing Pawn to D4 and now Bishop to D3
Magnus wants to play Bishop D4 and then
Advance the pawn to D3 as you have to
develop the Bishop um uh to to somehow
and black will probably also challenge
that with Bishop to E6 followed by
Bishop to D5 so Bishop to E6 ordan goes
for it right away Bishop to E4 and now
Bishop to D5 offering a trade right away
D3 and here there is a game where Queen
to D7 was played by the ordan just
Castle King side and it is now as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game so Magnus continues developing
Bishop to F4 puts pressure on C7 and
Bishop to B 4 attacks The Rook on E1
Rook to E2 and now Rook to C8 adding
another Defender uh we have Bishop back
to D2 offering a trade and Jordan goes
back Bishop to
E7 uh Queen to E1 aligning the the queen
and Rook nicely with the bishop on E7
and here we have a trade Bishop captures
on e4 Rook captures and now Pawn to F5
forcing The Rook to move back Rook to E2
and now Bishop to F6 nicely defending
that pawn and if um it's somehow
possible to go after the C2 Pawn could
become very relevant in the future as it
is a backwards Pawn not going to be easy
to advance it so Pawn to B4 by Magnus uh
and now Queen to D5 getting the queen
into the game uh Pawn to H4 and now Pawn
to H6 with have Bishop to F4 again
putting pressure on that C7 Pawn uh and
King to H7 just improving the position
of the king a little bit Queen to D2 and
now Rook F to E8 offering a trade of
Rooks uh which Magnus goes for it seems
like Jordan under the C7 Pawn but um not
really he does have a way of winning the
the material back Rook captures on E8
Rook captures and Bishop captures on C7
but now Bishop to E7 going after the B4
pawn and his idea is if Magnus defends
it let's say Rook B1 then he's going to
play Queen A2 attack the rook and D4
pawn and he's going to win material back
this way so instead Pawn to B5 by Magnus
we have captur sorry captures captures
and queen captures on B5 we have Queen
to F4 now uh and uh Bishop to F6 uh so
okay it's equal material and the only
one with the pass Pawn is Jordan with
that pass uh it's not still a pass Pawn
yet but uh the C2 Pawn is weak so maybe
he could somehow take advantage of that
we have Pawn to H5 by Magnus uh and now
King back to G8 we have Queen to D6 uh
and now Pawn to F4 uh giving giving up
the F4 Pawn but you will capture the H5
Pawn so Magnus goes Queen D7 at attacks
The Rook on E8 and now Queen captures on
H5 grabbing the pawn while defending the
rook and now Bishop captures on F4 so
restoring material uh and now Queen to
F7 Jordan offers a queen trade and the
Magnus trades we have captures captures
and now just Rook to B1 so well C2 is
weak uh B7 could be even weaker because
this is a backwards Pawn but it's not
easy to attack it the only way to attack
it as it's on a light Square you cannot
use the dark Square Bishop is for the
Knight to somehow reach that Pawn maybe
via the A3 or B4 squares or the for the
Knight to move and then for The Rook to
go after the pawn uh that's why Magnus
utilizes The Rook on the B file puts
pressure on B7 and now the Rook has to
defend it Rook to E7 and now King F1
Magnus starts bringing the king into the
game we have Pawn to G5 Bishop to H2 and
now Rook to D7 uh Pawn to G4 Magnus
stops any further expansion on the king
Side by Jordan and Jordan plays King to
G6 he says I will have to play Pawn to
H5 so Rook to B5 and now Pawn to H5
nonetheless G captures on H5 King
captures King to G2 and now King back to
G6 so you can advance the G Pawn if
needed Knight to D2 now going for that
E4 or or C4 squares we have Knight to A7
attacking the rook and Rook back to
B2 defending the C2 Pawn if if needed uh
in up front uh Knight back to C6 and now
Knight to C4 by Magnus we have Pawn to
G4 now uh and Rook to B5 grabbing hold
of the fifth rank so not allowing ordan
to advance any further Rook to E7 and
now uh Bishop to D6 uh putting pressure
on The Rook Rook to H7 and now Knight
back to D2 preparing to shift the Knight
over to E4 Knight to A7 again attacking
the rook and Magnus again goes back we
have King to F5 and now Knight to E4 and
here it's a very uh a tricky situation
where Jordan has to figure out how to
continue because a lot of his pieces are
are tied down uh he could consider
something just like Knight to C6 repeat
the position or he could go Bishop back
to d8 if he doesn't want to trade Bishop
for Knight but he actually goes Bishop
to E5 he wants to trade Bishop for
Bishop and okay Magnus trades we have
captures captus and now King to G3 and
here uh Jordan played King to G7 Rook to
G7 and the position is now uh very much
winning for Magnus but you have to
figure out how to do it it's very uh
simple once you see it but it's not easy
to see it so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Magnus while
I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and always
being a true Master of the end game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Rook to B6 that's the way
to do it uh and this is what Magnus
played and now once you look at the
position there really isn't all that
much Jordan can do uh uh how do you how
do you play this if you move the king
then you allow the white king to go to
F4 if you go to F5 uh not much better
just Knights to D6 check will lose you
the B7 Pawn uh what else can you try you
can move the Knight let's say Knight to
C8 you go after the Rook then comes Rook
B5 check and after King to E6 you will
play Knight to G5 check and win the G4
Pawn this way doesn't matter if you
attack King captures and G4 uh defends
the Knight so uh there's just no good
move it's it's sort of a t Swang uh Rook
to B6 was played like I said by Magnus
and now Rook to C7 Jordan tries
something uh it seems like he can
capture the C2 Pawn but not really
Magnus just captures on G4 and uh Jordan
of course moves The Rook back as you see
what happens if he captures on C2 it's
mate in two F4 check and after the king
moves Rook to D6 Checkmate that's the
idea so after King captures on G4 Jordan
had to go back Rook to F7 but this is
now already resigned territory Pawn to f
F3 Rook to F4 check and King to G3 we
have Rook back to F7 by ordan and now
Pawn to F4 with check seems like he's um
giving up a pawn but Magnus will take
the B7 Pawn uh instead so Jordan just
decided not to do it he played King
captur on D5 said he wanted to uh
preserve his B7 Pawn uh but by doing so
he ran into a mate in one so he was in
this position before Magnus even played
it on move 56 that Jordan Forest
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here Rook to D6 will be
Checkmate of course and that's why he
resigned so uh very very interesting
game and you can see how different it is
from the previous seven games that
Magnus played where he really really
struggled so what's the difference here
Jordan is an elite player he's at 20
okay now he's 2700 he was probably even
27 I don't know maybe 2730 at some point
uh so how how does he Magnus play so so
easily and so uh you know effortlessly
against a player of uh Jordan skill and
then struggles with 2500 players well
because Jordan for one uh is actively
trying to beat Magnus that's a that's a
pretty big deal while the other players
are very much satisfied with a draw and
um they they might you know Force Magnus
to push for something uh but Jordan here
played very actively and he also I
wanted to to get his chance and it's
always easier to beat someone if they
are also trying to beat you so so some
of you were asking in the comments that
um why why is Magan struggling so so
much it's not that he's struggling he's
still undefeated in all of the games
that he played uh he just drew three of
them uh which you know still lost him
some rating but now I think maybe with
the win against Jordan maybe he's now
actually um in in in a plus with rating
yeah he's actually with with a win
against Jordan uh he's actually on plus
z.6 so yeah it's very hard to to
actually gain rating if you're Magnus
and if you guys are interested in how
Norway did against Netherlands I think
the the game is still actually still
being played let me just um check this
out yeah Magnus won two boards Drew and
uh yeah tar versus max farmer still
being played it seems to be an equal
position we'll see what happens there uh
so yeah that's the game hope you enjoyed
it and hope you were able to spot this
Rook to B6 move not an easy one to find
but you know that's why I always say you
have to study the end game at at least
solve you know 5050 puzzles before
breakfast and and you will be okay uh so
I would like to thank Max and my chess
club Jeff markson Derek King aked halabi
and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and continuing the
coverage of the European Team
Championship until it finishes as so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day